casa sin techos y vehículos volcados dos
inéditos tornados causaron importantes
daños materiales en la región de Front
al norte de Francia un fenómeno
meteorológico inhabitual en esta región
y en esta época del año y otra de las
consecuencias de la crisis climática
lo que pasó es que en unos segundos
entró viento y nubes muy oscura si es
cierto que cuando no estás acostumbrado
a este tipo de hechos es muy
impresionante
y Pese a que la emergencia climática es
un problema global las afectaciones
demuestran grandes inequidades siendo
las naciones del sur global y las
comunidades más vulnerables los más
golpeados por los efectos del
calentamiento y el incremento de los
fenómenos extremos en el último panel
intergubernamental sobre el cambio
climático lo atacan entre otras
desigualdades al racismo y el clasicismo
lo que está sucediendo pasa en todo el
mundo pero esas comunidades que son más
pobres esas comunidades que son negras
indígenas comunidades de color a menudo
son golpeados más duramente en torno a
la crisis climática Y eso es porque hay
sistemas de ingresos clases razas que
siempre están en juego
Always and Play desde México hasta
bangladesh los ciclones huracanes y
tormentas extremas fuera de temporada se
siguen sucediendo mientras los expertos
piden soluciones globales que pasan
entre otras por crear planes de acción
climática más ambiciosos para eliminar
las emisiones de carbono